hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
where i react to basically whatever you
guys send me in my dms
this reaction is going to be to the clip
only fans girls belong to the subway
or the streets superheated in miami
uh this was sent to me via instagram so
if you guys have a clip
that you guys would want me to react to
send it to me on instagram because i
literally always check those messages um
yeah and don't forget to subscribe
before i start i'm gonna just keep this
intro
quick
[Music]
uh kevin welcome to the show man now
let's play big bang take a little bank
kevin [ __ ] samuels
[Music]
how are we doing what's up kevin one
thing that i heard
from the ladies that i often heard when
i spent
a lot of time in corporate strip clubs
with high-end escorts
porn stars the new girls to the industry
all thought they discovered fire
because they were hot what the fees was
trying to tell you ladies
is the money you're making
is seasonal there will be a new
it chick every season
and what ends up happening is if you
don't take the money you have
while you're hot and if you're not
flexible enough
to listen to people who know better
you'll just have a lot of money that you
blow
now i don't know why so many women think
only fans
is this open fount of money
it's a it's money only fans is at scale
now
and we have no history on women going
a decade of making money same store
sales year over year
on this platform so everything that i
heard from you ladies
is the most optimistic projections if
nothing changes
but it's open so it's not possible for
it to be for
10 years because it hasn't even been a
decade since the website has just
okay yeah but there's been like
different types of
sex work that's been out
forever that's what i just said sex work
has been around since
forever but that's what right so so like
i was saying i
traffic in places where high-end dancers
escort sex work
ladies how do you honestly think you're
going to make
increasing money over the next 10 years
you have to think like do you think
you're going to make a ton of money when
you're like
60 50. it ends at some point
i've increased my money exponentially
every single month
since i started money fans that's a
month and that's and that's every month
but i said over the next 10 years you've
been in this business for right about a
year
right that's 10 years old yet
that's not the question well any
business
and here's the thing and this is what
and like okay i would never
recommend someone i love to go on only
fans
however like if you're gonna like play
the sex work game or do that
make a ton of money for a short amount
of time
and then get out and invest your money
like if that's
how you want to do it there's girls that
do it successfully i just
not for me what i mean by the
hard-hittedness piece of it
in order to be able to take the money
you've made and apply the so-called
knowledge you have
you need to be able to work and leverage
it with people who know more than you
instead of looking her fees in the face
like he doesn't know what he's talking
about
when he runs a million dollar almost
million dollar business
the guys on the podcast are on the verge
of running a million dollar business
and another person who knows how to do
it is run most of it
you're asking me questions to prove to
you like i don't know what i'm talking
about
i don't think you know what you're
talking about regarding only fans that's
for sure because
i don't know what i'm talking about as
far as business and making money
in regards to making money money comes
in waves and we all have to understand
that and if we all invest successfully
we could
where are you investing where are you oh
people are where are you investing
average you should
i just i already know where this is
going where are you investing
that's none of your business it's it's
it's secret
yeah you know the question okay but it's
not even hard to just put your money in
an indexed fund
i'm not i'm not super into the stock
market but
like i've made a decent return on
investment just by using the index and
index fund
except what you just said but you said
money comes in wage granted
we have to invest it's taken where's
some of the places you're investing
yeah see
this is what this is what this only fan
economy is done
it's let women with really low
functioning knowledge
no high value or high ticket skills
that's not low functioning large
knowledge
uh well let's talk okay every time i've
asked you
i've asked you any question about
business and you've asked me a question
instead of answering it
and i said well and if it's not you eat
the meat spit out the bones but what
only fans has done
is it's created a bubble economy
women are coming rushing to only fans
thinking that it's the new
dot com the new real estate and they're
realizing
that there is no sustainable way to
project this out
for over five years now maybe you don't
know that knowledge but i do
because i well anyway anyway so you can
go with the club
like we're not ready but you understand
that
what he's not trying literally anyone
can get in if you pay
the price to hate and so now but listen
i'm investing my only fantasy
money into body contouring he's asking
my friend what is she investing in it
yeah
[Applause]
body contour that doesn't
oh my god
that's like plastic surgery to like fix
your body right
oh no no honey no just trying to make
her feel bad about that i'm doing it
until i
no no i asked her what she was investing
in i know whether it's good or bad
none of you guys pay my bills so why
would i tell you about my business on
this channel
i think guys
here's here's the reality the point of
the matter is that what you don't under
what we're trying to communicate is that
a lot of fields
that give people quick money whether
it's entertainment
whether it's sports whether it's acting
there's so many fields
that will give you quick money today and
when you get that money
you think you've made it look at all the
atlanta rappers look at all the
basketball players you think that you
made it because you're getting money
today
but a lot of these fields in 5 10
15 20 years you're not making the same
amount of money
it's not just you women and only fans
this is what the caveat that i am
curious about the internet is completely
different than anything that's been
around historically
so like i don't know when the internet
google this when was the internet
invented
okay the internet is it crazy 2007
that's crazy
so i feel like you don't actually know
what's gonna
stick around and what's not 14 years
that's crazy i can't believe it's only
been 14 years
like i'm 24. so it came when i was 10.
but you guys get what i'm saying like
he's like preaching that i won't be
around tomorrow but they really have no
idea
because it's only been 14 years
but i would i would bet that only fans
has an expiration date
with your looks it's also men as well
but the reality of the matter is
is that if you are not wise with your
money
if you are not long-sided with your
money if you don't have
actual investments like understanding
cryptocurrency like understanding mutual
funds like understanding stocks
when you when you're not educating
yourself on those matters what ends up
happening is you end up
losing your money and the reality of the
matter is for a lot of women who are
into
sex work you guys are short-sighted
individuals
so if you if you're a short-sighted
person more than likely you're not
spending your money
you're buying bags you're buying nice
apartments that only fans is just sex
work
amen i it blows my mind
okay i have a story for you guys
personally i'm
so cheap i people will make fun of me on
tiktok
because i literally have no style and
it's actually not that i have no style
i do i just don't have the money for a
closet and i don't want to spend money
on it
and but here's the thing i have
friends that i see like buy new clothes
every single month first job they got
they got a new car
and i i'm just sitting here like don't
you guys want to save your money
like like oh my gosh girls are so bad
with money
i was doing youtube for six months
basically making no money and i
literally like
lent friends money like
i didn't say but i'm buying bags like
who said i don't know let me let me
finish
let me finish hold on hold on hold on
hold on see that's see
you can't do that i ask you what you're
buying and what you're investing in and
you didn't want to say
it so when hafiz makes an assumption
then you want to question that
see here's what we have going on this is
what i said about being hard-headed
be more open-minded
because at the end of the day i'm
leaving it with a negative message from
this podcast
okay they're so they're getting mad
because there's some truth to it
like you because um can somebody grab
some control
because what i need to do
no no no real quick real quick real
quick
ladies ladies ladies ladies ladies we're
gonna we're just gonna express the
opinions uh me
and fresh are not and we're gonna let
you and hafiz and kevin talk about this
and then you guys can give your points
everyone's gonna get a form to speak the
word
the man that you don't even know her you
have no place to tell her how and where
to invest her money how to make her
money i didn't tell her where anything i
just asked what she was doing
this is what i mean this is what i mean
guys this is what i mean this is
he's trying to be as measured as
possible i came in trying to be as
measured as possible
and what are we getting we're getting
attacked we're getting angry we're
getting you don't know why nothing you
don't know
what i do know what i do know what i do
know what i do
what i do know what i do know
is event of all the business people on
this platform
the people who are going to have
long-term success are not you
damn okay so i'll see
you're saying it's not me you will see
that's the girl that said she's
investing in body contour
we'll see if i won't be successful
and my my point that i was simply trying
to bring up
if you feel offended that's how you feel
but you're you you wait no no no no
new york new york you had a chance to
talk the reality of the matter is
there is a way whether you're upset or
not that you talk to people
i have not been trying to be
disrespectful to you i have not raised
my tone
i have attempted to allow you to
communicate and not talk over you
so what's not gonna happen is that as
adults
that you don't you're gonna treat me one
way and i'm gonna treat you a different
way
the same way that you want me to be
respectful to listen
to you and to try to have a conversation
with you i ask that you do the same
if we if we cannot follow those rules
then you can exit the conversation
because
we are simply trying to have a
conversation here i
if you felt like somebody new york you
have to let people
talk you see this is the re this is the
problem
now and you see these two girls are just
like laughing at it like they're so
disrespectful
i feel like girls like their parents did
not teach them how to like be
respected getting into the problem with
modern society because the
whole reason i even got here is because
there was certain attitudes
i was seeing that you guys were
inhibited because remember the initial
question was
what are characteristics about yourself
that could be a turn off to a guy
and some of those things in regards to
the attitude could you start off by
saying well i'm independent
right but it's not your independence
it's your attitude and the reality of
the matter is
the kind of guys that you want have a
choice
they're not going to choose this kind of
attitude so when you're attractive when
you have a nice body when you pay for
money
pay for things and all that stuff you
can get attention but the reality is
with that kind of attitude you will not
get retention
and so all day long the the fundamental
reality is when you're 20.
there's some guys that'll stick around
and you have your looks
yeah use your looks to leverage whatever
you can get but that eventually runs out
that eventually runs out and at the end
of the day what's going to happen is
you're going to be at a point in your
life
where all you're going to have is who
you are as a person and if you have not
spent time
energy effort and resources into
investing into yourself to becoming a
better person
what you're going to be is by yourself
and so
and my my hope for these conversations
is that we as men and women can talk to
one another
and build one one another up but to sit
down here to tear
each other down and to come with this
negative attitude
and it's condescending demeanor that's
not the productive way we need to move
forward
and we can have a conversation about it
go ahead you got something and then
we'll turn it to kevin and then we'll
let you speak as well yeah damaris yeah
so
go ahead sorry
it's fine it's open forum you know what
i'm saying say your piece i i saw that
you wanted to say something earlier
no i retired and me too i felt like you
said you were being
um respectful but you weren't as a man i
feel like you have no place
to tell women how to make
their um but he never once told you how
to make your money he's saying
have a long term plan if you want to
make your money
doing only fans like power tea there's
girls that make millions
and you can invest invest that millions
into like retirement into a 401k
whatever
but if you don't have a long-term plan
like money
and then you're referring to it as a sex
industry just because
you have only fans doesn't mean you're
having sex on it you could be cooking on
only fans you could do whatever you want
so i just feel like i'm just offended
and it's
not just him or it's me it's towards
women because
men have no place at all to say how
women
should and should we have every place we
built the goddamn world you live in
no you didn't i'm going to die it's
built by men
i'm going to say nobody made this about
men or women not get paid
here so this is what tends to happen
when
whether it's only fans tick tock
instagram
and when women can't handle it they
leave
this is the point this is about business
business isn't offensive but when people
and their lack of
knowledge gets exposed they get offended
they call themselves experts and
business owners and everything else your
online strippers would make a little bit
of money congratulations
i'm good with escorts i'm good with
strippers but when someone like harpis
or myself tries to sit down and talk to
you about your level of ignorance
you're offended your ignorance is what
offends you it's offensive to me that
you're going to try to make this about
men
and sexism this is what the world has
done it's got
little pampered princesses who can get
online
make some money and think that they're
on the same level as men who built this
world and they are not
that's what you just saw them leave
because they can't go get onto wall
street
main street anywhere into a bank into
anybody's business to be taken seriously
with their so-called business plan or
their go to market strategy
you're taking what the world is giving
you your creators giving you and you put
it online
thank men for building the internet the
computers the smartphone and everything
else
that allows you to sit up in your luxury
apartment and get paid for showing your
feet
we did that you
okay i don't have this like i hate men
attitude
but i would never say like
you know i mean i would never say like
oh we birth children we do this we do
that as women because
i haven't and i really don't like
arguing and like generalities like
we all did this like kevin
you didn't i mean he he's successful he
built
a lot of different stuff but like he's
trying to
be a part of the credit for like the
internet
i don't know if you guys understand what
i'm saying and in 10 years
when no one wants to see your feet or
your g-string or your tattoos or
whatever else
of these uh chris the roommate the
roommates uh
mario fresh not mario man um
we will all be still running our
businesses because we don't get
emotional about business when somebody
tells us we have a hole in our game
we humble ourselves we check ourselves
we get better that's what men do
because we have the pr we have the
business of building the world we can't
[ __ ] walk off like
babies because it happened i didn't like
it see atlas can't shrug
if we shrugged you would die that's what
happens
every time one of you little crybabies
gets called out here
on the platform you came to to get
attention you asked for
when you get more smoke than you're
willing to handle you want to cry and
stomp off well
kick rocks and guess what there'll be a
new one tomorrow
because neither one of y'all on the
panel can honestly say
that you are bringing something to the
market that ain't 15 of other chicas
down on the street bringing
none so we sit here and try to have a
conversation with you and tell you guess
what
whether you're instagram facebook tick
tock whatever
every new influencer every new person
thinks just because they have the dope
content
they've got the [ __ ] key they got the
they've been discovered fire they've
invented the wheel and there's more that
goes into it
than just turning on a camera and saying
hi i'm on youtube i'm on facebook i'm on
only fans it takes planning it takes
work it takes strategy
it takes business knowledge it takes
collaboration it takes a lot of things
that you
obviously don't have and that's why
you're upset because at the end of the
day
you know you don't have them and you
don't have the patience the intelligence
even the patience the patience the
intelligence even the resources to sit
down and just listen
so carry your cell phone and when only
fans stops
subway will be hiring oh my god
[Applause]
oh my god he just destroyed them
um
my only caveat is i feel like people
don't really know
the future of the internet because it's
only been 14 years
but i'd be curious to see
where like the internet stars of today
like take the demilios
those girls that girl has a 100 million
followers
on tick tock i don't know what she has
on youtube
around um
charlie okay let's see what does she
have on
41 million on instagram like that's more
than kevin
has ever done like in his entire life
this little girl did
and i'm nothing like to discount him i'm
sure he makes a lot of money too
but to act like that's like a hundred
million people
41 million people are just gonna go away
those kids are going to grow up and
still buy stuff from you
just just my two cents but if you guys
have any thoughts on like
what internet celebrities have like come
and gone and like how
if they became successful or not let me
know in the comments
don't forget to subscribe i'll talk to
you guys next time